considering that I have a cold right now
I can't imagine a more appropriate topic
to make a video on than a virus I don't
wanna make it that thick a virus or
viruses viruses and in my opinion
viruses are on some level the most
fascinating thing in all of biology
because they they really blur the
boundary between what is an inanimate
object and what is life what is life I
mean if we look at ourselves or you know
life is one of those things that you
know it when you see it if you see
something that it's born it grows it
it's constantly changing maybe it moves
around maybe it doesn't but it's
metabolizing things around itself it
reproduces and then it dies you say hey
that's probably life and in this we
throw most things that we see or you
know we throw in us we throw in bacteria
we throw in plants I mean I could I
could I'm kind of butchering the
taxonomy system here but we we tend to
know life when we see it but all viruses
are is there they're just a bunch of
genetic information inside of a protein
and set of a protein capsule so let me
let me draw so let's say and they
connect information can come in any form
so it can be you know it could be an RNA
it could be DNA it could be
single-stranded RNA double-stranded RNA
sometimes they'll write you know for
single-stranded all right these two
little SS in front of it for say they're
talking about double-stranded DNA
they'll put a des in front of it but the
general idea and viruses can come in all
of these forms is that they have some
genetic information some new clay some
chain of nucleic acids either as single
or double stranded RNA or single or
double stranded DNA and it's just in
contained inside some type of protein
structure which is called a capsid and
kind of the classic the classic drawing
is kind of an eye I saw so Hedren type
looking thing let me see if I can do
justice to it looks something like this
and not all viruses have to look exactly
like this there's thousands of types of
viruses and we're really just scratching
the surface and understanding even what
virus is out there and all of the
different ways that they can essentially
get
kind of replicate themselves and we'll
talk more about that in the future and I
and I would suspect that pretty much any
possible way of replication probably
does somehow exist in the virus world
but they really are just these proteins
these protein capsids is just made up by
a bunch of little proteins put together
and inside they have some genetic
material which might be DNA or might be
RNA so let me draw their genetic
material a little you know the protein
is not necessarily transparent but if it
was you would see you would see some
genetic material inside of there and so
the question is is this is this thing
life it seems pretty an adamant it
doesn't grow it doesn't change it
doesn't metabolize things this thing
left to its own devices is just going to
sit there it's just going to sit there
the way a book on our table just sits
there it doesn't it won't change
anything but what happens is the I guess
the the debate arises I mean you might
say hey Sal when you define it that way
just looks like a bunch of molecules put
together that isn't life but it starts
to seem like life all of a sudden when
it comes in contact with the things that
we normally consider life so what
viruses do the classic the classic
example is a virus will attach it to
self to a cell so let's let me draw this
thing a little bit smaller so let's say
that this is my virus I'll draw it as a
little hexagon and what it does is it'll
attach itself to a cell it could be any
type of cell could be a bacterial cell
it could be a a plant cell it could be a
human cell let me draw the cell here the
cells are usually far larger than the
virus and the case of cells that have
soft membranes the virus figures out
some way to enter it sometimes it can
essentially fuse it's so I'll I don't
want to I don't want to complicate the
issue but sometimes viruses have their
own little membranes and we'll talk
about in a second where it gets their
membrane so a virus might have its own
membrane like that that's around its
capsid and then these membranes will
fuse and then the virus will be able to
enter into the cell now that's one
method another method and they're seldom
all the same way but let's say another
method would be the virus convinces just
by based on some protein
scepters on it or protein receptors on
the cells and obviously this has to be
kind of a Trojan horse type of thing the
cell doesn't want viruses though so the
virus has to somehow convince the cell
that it's a non foreign particle but
that we could do a we can do hundreds of
videos on how viruses work and it's a
continuing field of research but
sometimes you might have a virus that
just gets consumed by the cell maybe the
cell just thinks it's something that it
needs to consume so the cell wraps
around it like this the cell will wrap
around it like this and these sides will
eventually merge and then the cell and
the virus will go into it this is called
endocytosis I'll just talk about that it
brings it into its cytoplasm and doesn't
happen just endocytosis doesn't happen
just to viruses but this is one
mechanism that can enter and then in
cases where the where the cell in
question for example in this situation
with bacteria if the cell has a very
hard shell if the cell is let me do it
in good color so let's say that this is
a bacteria right here it has a hard
shell the viruses don't even enter the
cell they just hang out outside of the
cell like this not drawing the scale and
they actually inject their genetic
material so there's obviously a huge
there's a wide variety of ways of how
the viruses get into cell but that's
beside the point the interesting thing
is that they do get into the cell and
once they do get into the cell they
release their genetic material into the
cell so the genetic material will float
around if their genetic material is
already in the form of RNA and you know
this almost I can imagine almost every
possibility of different ways for
viruses to work probably do exist in
nature we just haven't found them but
the ones that we've already found really
do kind of do it in every possible way
so if if they have RNA this RNA can
immediately can immediately start being
used to and essentially let's say this
is the nucleus of the cell that's the
nucleus of the cell and it normally has
the DNA in it like that maybe I'll do
the DNA a different color but DNA DNA
gets gets Trent it gets transcribed into
RNA normally so normally the cell just a
normal working cell the
RNA exits the nucleus it goes to the
ribosomes and then you have the RNA in
conjunction with the tRNA and it
produces these proteins right proteins
the RNA codes for different proteins and
I talked about that in the in a
different video so these proteins get
formed and eventually you know they can
form the different structures in a Cell
but what a virus does is it hijacks this
process here hijacks this mechanism this
RNA will essentially go and do what the
cells own RNA would have done and it
starts coding for its own proteins
obviously it's not going to code for the
same things there and actually some of
the first proteins that code for often
start killing the DNA and the RNA that
might otherwise compete with it so it's
codes its own proteins and then those
proteins start making more viral shells
so those proteins just start
constructing more and more viral shells
and at the same time this RNA is
replicating it's using the the cells own
mechanisms left to its own devices it
would just sit there but once it enters
into a cell it can use all of the nice
machinery that a cell has around to
replicate itself and then I'm it's kind
of amazing just with just the the
biochemistry of it that these that these
RNA molecules and find themselves back
in these capsids and then once there's
enough of these and the the cell has
essentially all of its resources have
been depleted the viruses these these
individual new viruses that have
replicated themselves using all of the
all of the the cell's mechanisms will
find some way to exit the cell the the
kind of the most I don't want to say
typical because we haven't even
discovered all the different types of
viruses there are but one that I guess
talked about the most is that when
there's enough of these they'll release
proteins or they'll construct proteins
because they don't make their own that
essentially cause the cell to either
kill itself or its membrane to dissolve
so the membrane dissolves and
essentially the cell lysis let me write
that down
the cell lysis and lysis just means that
the cell's membrane just disappears and
then all of these guys can emerge from
them cell now I talked about before that
you know you have
some of these guys that they have their
own membrane so how did they get there
you know these these kind of vide lipid
membranes or some of them what they do
is once they replicate inside of a cell
once they replicate inside of a cell the
exit maybe not even killing they don't
have to lyse you know everything I
talked about these are specific ways
that a virus might work but viruses
really kind of explore every well the
different types of viruses do almost
every different combination you can
imagine of replicating and and and and
coding for proteins and then escaping
from cells some of them just bud and
when they bud they essentially you can
kind of imagine that they push against
the cell wall or the membrane I
shouldn't say cell wall the the cells
outer membrane and then when they push
against it they take some of the
membrane with them and so eventually the
cell will you know when this goes up
enough this will pop together and
they'll take some of the membrane with
it and you could you could imagine why
that would be a useful thing to have
with you because now that you have this
membrane you kind of look like this cell
so when you want to go infect another
cell like this it's you're not going to
necessarily look like a foreign particle
so it's a very useful way to kind of
look like something that you're not and
if you didn't if you don't think that
this is creepy-crawly enough that you
know you're hijacking the DNA of an
organism cells can actually change of
irises can actually change the DNA of
the Norgan ism and actually one of the
most common examples is HIV virus let me
write that down
HIV which is a type of retrovirus
retrovirus which is fascinating because
what they do is so they have RNA in them
they have RNA and them and when they
enter into a cell let's say that they
got into the cell so it's inside of the
cell like this they they actually bring
along with them a protein and you you
know every time you say where did they
get this protein King all of this stuff
came from a different cell they use some
other cells amino acids and ribosomes
and nucleic acids and everything to
build themselves and he saw any proteins
that they have in them came from another
cell but they use this they bring with
them this protein reverse transcriptase
and the reverse transcriptase takes
their RNA and codes it encodes it into
DNA
so it's RNA to DNA which was first
discovered was you know it kind of
people always thought that you always
went from DNA to RNA but this kind of
broke that paradigm but it codes from
RNA to DNA and if that's not bad enough
it'll incorporate it'll incorporate that
DNA into the DNA of the host cell so
that DNA if this would that DNA will
incorporate itself to the DNA of the
whole let's say the yellow is the DNA of
the host cell and this is its nucleus
so it actually messes with the genetic
makeup of what it's infecting and you
know when I made the videos on bacteria
I said hey you know where we have for
every one human cell we have 20
bacterial cell and they live with us and
they're useful and they're part of us
and they're 10% of our dry mass and all
of that but bacteria are kind of along
for the ride they don't change who we
are but these retroviruses they're
actually changing our genetic makeup I
mean I my genes I take very personally
they define who I am but these these
guys will actually go in and change my
genetic makeup and then once they're
part of the DNA then just the natural
DNA to RNA to protein process will code
will code their actual proteins or their
what they need to so you know sometimes
they'll lay dormant and do nothing and
sometimes well say you know sometimes
it's some type of environmental trigger
they'll start coding for themselves
again and they'll start producing more
but they're producing it directly from
the organisms from the cell's DNA they
become part of the organism I mean I
can't imagine a more intimate way to
become part of an organism than to
become part of its DNA I can't imagine
any other way to actually define and an
organism and if this if this by itself
is not URI enough and and just so you
know this this notion right here when a
virus becomes part of an organism's DNA
this is called a pro virus Pro virus but
if this isn't eerie enough they estimate
so you know if this just if this
a cell in my I don't know in my nose or
in my arm it'll you know as the cell
experiences mitosis all of its its
offspring but this I off spring her
genetic identical are going to have this
viral DNA and that might be fine but at
least my children won't get it you know
at least it won't become part of my
species but it doesn't have to just
infect somatic cells it could infect a
germ cell so it could it could go into a
germ cell and the germ cells we've
learned already these are the ones that
produce gametes for men that's sperm and
for women it's egg eggs but you can
imagine once you've infected a germ cell
once you become part of a germ cells DNA
that I'm passing on that viral DNA to my
son or my daughter and he they're going
to pass it on to their children and you
know just that idea by itself is at
least to my mind vaguely creepy and
people estimate that five to eight
percent and this kind of really blurs
you know it makes you think about what
we as humans really are but the estimate
is five to eight percent of the human
genome of human genome so when I talked
about bacteria I just thought talked
about things that were along for the
ride but the the current estimated I
looked up this a lot I found eight
percent someplace five percent someplace
it's all I guess I mean people are doing
it based on just looking at the DNA and
how similar it is DNA and other
organisms but the estimate is five to
eight percent of the human genome is
from viruses is from like ancient
retroviruses that incorporated
themselves into the into the human
germline so into into human DNA so these
are called endogenous retroviruses and
dajin Asst retroviruses which is
mind-blowing to me because it's not just
saying these things are along for the
ride or that they might help us or hurt
us it's saying that we are out five to
eight percent of our DNA actually comes
from viruses and this is another thing
that speaks to just genetic variation
because viruses do sorry I mean this you
can this is called you know I guess you
could call it a horizontal transfer of
DNA because you can imagine as a virus
goes from one species to the next
as it goes from you know species A to B
if it mutates to be able to infiltrate
B's cells it might take some but it'll
take the DNA that it has that it already
that makes it it with it but sometimes
when it starts coding for some of these
other guys so let's say that this is a
pro virus right here where this is the
blue part is the original virus the
yellow is the is the organisms I guess
historic DNA sometimes when it codes it
takes up little sections of the other
organisms DNA so you know maybe most of
it was the viral DNA but it might have
when it transcribed and translated
itself it might have taken a little bit
or at least when it translated or
replicate itself it might take a little
bit of the organisms previous DNA so
it's actually cutting parts of DNA from
one organism and bringing it to another
organism taking it from one member of a
species to another member of the species
but it can definitely go cross species
so you have this idea of all of a sudden
that DNA can jump between species and it
really kind of I don't know for me it
makes me appreciate how interconnected
you know we've species we kind of
imagine that we're by ourselves and we
can only reproduce with each other and
have genetic variation within a
population but viruses introduce this
notion of horizontal transfer via
transduction and trans transfer
horizontal transduction is just the idea
of look when I when I replicate this
virus I might take a little bit of the
the organism that I'm used that I'm kind
of freeloading off of I might take a
little bit of their DNA with me and
infect that DNA into the next organism
so you actually have this DNA that's
jumping from organism to organism so it
kind of unifies all you know all like
it's a DNA base life which is all the
life that we know on on the planet and
if all of this all of this isn't creepy
enough and actually maybe I didn't I'll
save the creepiest part for the end but
there's a whole class you could talk all
about the different classes of viruses
but just so that you're familiar with
some of the terminology when a virus
when a virus attacks bacteria which they
often do and we studied these often the
most because this might be a good
alternative to antibiotics because virus
that attack bacteria might you know
sometimes the bacteria is far worse for
the virus but these are called bacteria
phages
bacteria phages and I've already talked
to you about and you know they have
their DNA but since bacteria of hard
walls will just inject the DNA inside of
the bacteria and you know when you talk
about when you talk about DNA this idea
of kind of a provirus so when a virus
you know lysis it like this is called
the lytic cycle this is just some
terminology that's good to know if
you're going to take a biology exam
about this stuff and when the virus
incorporates it into this DNA and lays
dormant it incorporates into the DNA of
the host organism and lays dormant for a
while this is called the lysogenic cycle
and normally although you know provirus
is essentially experiencing a lysogenic
cycle in eukaryotes in organisms that
that that have a nuclear membrane
normally when people talk about the
lysogenic cycle they're talking about
viral DNA laying dormant in the DNA of
bacteria or bacteria phage DNA light
laying dormant in the in the DNA of
bacteria but just to kind of give you an
idea of what this quote-unquote looks
like what this looks like right here I
got these two pictures from Wikipedia
one is from the CDC this is actually so
this is these little green dots and this
was colored I think the original picture
was in black and white these little
green dots you see right all over the
surface this this big thing you see here
this is a white blood cell this is a
white blood cell part of the human
immune system so this is a white blood
cell white blood cell and what you see
emerging from the surface essentially
budding from the surface of this white
blood cell and this gives you a sense of
scale - these are HIV one viruses and
just so you're you're familiar and this
is why it's so you're familiar with the
terminology the eight is HIV is the
virus that it infects I guess you can
call it infects white blood cells AIDS
is the syndrome you get once your immune
system is weakened to the point and then
many people you know they suffer
infections that people with a strong
immune system normally won't suffer from
but this is creepy I mean these things
went inside this huge cell they used the
cells own or mechanism to reproduce its
own DNA or its own RNA and these protein
capsids and then they bud from the cell
and they take a little bit of the
membrane with it and they can even leave
some of their DNA behind in this cells
own DNA so they really change what the
cell is all about this is another creepy
picture these are right here or bacteria
phages these are bacteria phages
bacteria phages and these show you what
I said before this is a bacteria right
here this is this is its cell wall and
it's hard so it's hard to just kind of
just emerge into it or you can't just
merge fuse membranes with it so they
hang out on the outside they hang out on
the outside of this bacteria and they're
essentially injecting their genetic
material into it into the bacteria
itself and you could imagine just
looking at the size of these things I
mean this is a cell and it looks like a
whole planet or something or not you
know or this is a bacteria and these
things are so much smaller roughly one
hundredth of a bacteria and these are
much less than one hundredth of this
cell we're talking about they're
extremely hard to kind of to filter for
to kind of keep out because they are
such such small particles but you know
just if you think that you know these
are only exotic things that exist for
things like you know a HIV or or Ebola
which which they do cause or SARS you're
right but they are also common things I
mean I said at the beginning of this
video that I have a cold and I have a
cold because some viruses have infected
the tissue in my in my nasal passage and
they're causing me to you know have a
runny nose and whatnot and you know
viruses also cause the chicken pox they
call it the herpes simplex virus causes
cold sores so they're with us all around
you I can almost guarantee you have some
virus with you as you speak they're all
around you but they can but it's just a
very I you know it's it's a very
philosophically puzzling question
because I started with at the beginning
you know are these life and at first
when I just
showed it to you is it look they're just
this you know protein with some nucleic
acid molecule in it and it's not doing
anything and that doesn't look like life
to me it's not moving around it doesn't
have a metabolism it's not eating it's
not reproducing but then all of a sudden
when you think about what it's doing to
cells and how it uses cells to kind of
reproduce it kind of like you know in
the business terms its asset light it
doesn't need all of the machinery
because it can use other people's
machinery to replicate itself it's
almost you almost kind of want to view
it as a a smarter form of life because
it does it doesn't it doesn't go through
all of the trouble of what you know
every other form of life has and it
makes you question what life is or even
what we are you know are we these things
that contain DNA or are we just are we
just transport mechanisms for the the
DNA and these are kind of the more
important things and you know these
viral infections are just battles
between different forms of DNA and RNA
whatnot anyway I don't want to get too
philosophical on you but I hopefully
this gives you a good idea of what
viruses are and what why they really are
in my mind the most fascinating pseudo
organism in all of biology